my name is daniel feld and i'm the owner
of cura home today we're going to go
through the process of deep cleaning air
ducts the purpose of an air duct is
essentially to provide fresh clean air
to your home
we provide air duct cleaning and routine
home maintenance services where it visit
our clients homes once a quarter
everything you're supposed to be doing
as a perfect homeowner but a lot of
people don't have the time or neglect to
do
when we clean the air ducts we go
through and we clean the entire system
so we start in the upper level and we
work our way all the way through the
entire home
depending on who and what is living in
the home the debris that we find inside
of air ducts consists of a lot of
different items such as skin cells dust
dander pet debris pet hair anything that
you would see when you maybe wipe your
feet off on a rug when you walk inside a
home can be found inside an air duct
this air duct has not been cleaned for
probably 50 plus years additionally the
person that lives in this home has also
smoked and had pets so this is a very
severe air duct that can actually smell
it it has an old house smell built up
over time
if it's a really light color often we're
finding sawdust or sheet rock dust that
is from construction debris as we get
into darker colors sometimes smoking
inside the home is going to leave more
of a yellow color and as it gets darker
a lot of times we're more concerned
about a humidity issue that can
eventually turn into a dark colored mold
you're getting a more hazardous material
in there
once the air duct cover is removed we're
going to allow the air compressor hose
to be put into the air duct before we're
turning on that hose we're going to put
a clear dome over the cover and we're
going to attach our hepa vacuum to the
dome once those items are in place we're
going to turn the air compressor on and
that allows the hose with a reverse
blasting ball to propel itself forward
into the air duct the clear dome that's
used is crucial because it creates a
sealed environment so we're getting all
the dust debris out of the home and
we're not creating a mess inside the
home but it's also crucial because it
creates a really nice suction area so
all the power from the air compressor
and the vacuum are working together to
pull and push the debris outside we can
twist and turn that hose so we can go
around any corner once we get to the end
trunk line we can feel that in the air
compressor hose and we're going to
slowly pull that back at about one foot
per second
as we're doing that we can see all the
dust and debris that is being removed
from the air duct come through that
clear dome and go in to the hepa vacuum
once we've completed the cleaning find
that a little bit of dust and debris has
come all the way at the end of the air
duct and it's really important to take
your vacuum and clean out that extra
debris that's come
often times that's where you're gonna
find the real treasures such as bugs
toys
dog toys bones items like that that have
been placed really far into the air duct
and all of our equipment has pulled it
out
in order to clean the dust and debris
that's found on the inside or outside
events you want to remove the vent first
and brush that off with the vacuum and
you're going to get a majority of dust
and debris off then we put the vent
cover back on and replace the screws
back to the original format and make
sure the area is nice and clean and
clear of debris
all the air in your home is circulating
through your furnace on a regular basis
and by having a clean clear furnace
filter it's going to catch all the dust
and debris that is circulating
throughout depending on the style of
furnace filter that you have you may
have one that needs to be cleaned on a
regular basis and you can do this by
using a hepa vacuum and brush locate the
furnace filter inside your furnace and
remove that door and pull that furnace
filter out the next thing you want to do
is take your vacuum and place that over
the furnace filter to make sure you're
cleaning that really nice and thoroughly
a dryer vent is allowing the exhaust
from a dryer to be pushed outside of the
home
the reason why is because over time lint
builds up inside that dryer vent
to properly clean a dryer vent usually
you just need an air compressor and you
can use a reverse blasting ball or whip
to place inside the dryer vent
we're going to find that exhaust on the
outside of the home and we're going to
place the air compressor hose inside the
dryer vent and we're going to turn that
on that will propel itself into the
dryer and dislodge all the lint that's
built up over time
there's heat that's being pushed through
that dryer vent and if the dryer vent
does not have proper air airflow it's
very easy for that lint to become
flammable and start on fire we recommend
having your dryer vent cleaned on an
annual basis to prevent the buildup of
the lint and decrease the chance of a
fire happening in your home
depending on your current health such as
if you have really bad allergies or not
that can play a really large factor on
the risk of living in a home with the
dirty air ducts we've had all kinds of
different results we've had people that
have told us that they slept through the
night for the first time after they had
their air ducts cleaned because the air
quality was improved that much
you